hallo herzlich willkommen
ich ziehe jetzt auch ganz elegant wieder
ab du kannst deine auf lassen
heute gibt es wieder ein rezept aus der
kategorie nachgemacht original trifft
sally und zwar werde ich heute dieses
features regeln die kennt ihr alle sind
schokoriegel mit nougat führung und
erdnüssen und mit einer karamell schicht
und die sind sehr lecker wie zeige ich
euch mal rockig gekleckert
hier seht ihr auch noch mal die schicht
und zwar seht ihr hier die schokoladen
schicht außenrum hier unten die
nutzschicht und dann kommt die karamell
schicht mit den erdnüssen und dann eben
noch mal die schokoladen und die werden
jetzt nach machen und dafür zeige ich
einmal die zutaten auf den ersten blick
sind es vielleicht viele zutaten aber im
endeffekt sind gar nicht so viele ich
werde euch jetzt einfach alle auf einmal
zeigen
damit ihr wisst was kommt und deswegen
gehen wir jetzt hier runter also wie
gesagt sieht es jetzt noch ganz viel aus
weil es einfach aus vier schichten
besteht aber im endeffekt sind es
eigentlich nur acht zutaten und zwar
braucht ihr für die erste schicht 100
gramm vollmilchschokolade 30 gramm
erdnussbutter für die zweite schicht
braucht ihr 30 gramm kondensmilch 30
gramm erdnussbutter 80 gramm zucker 25 g
butter 100 gramm erdnüsse die sind ganz
und gesalzen und wir brauchen 100 gramm
marshmallow flammen
ja und zwar kann man das einmal selbst
machen und es gibt aber auch fertig zu
kaufen und zwar habe ich das jetzt von
globus gekauft da gibt es bei uns eben
in der süßwarenabteilung und ich werde
euch aber am ende des videos auch zeigen
wie man das selbst herstellen für die
dritte schicht brauchen wir 30 gramm
kondensmilch und wir brauchen 150 gramm
karamellbonbons und zwar haben wir jetzt
hier die durch pfizer genommen
aber da gibt es zum beispiel auch diese
muss und die durchmesser
die gibt es eigentlich in jedem
supermarkt da sieht die packung so aus
es sind bonbons von storck und das sind
einfach cremig weiche karamellbonbons da
müsst ihr keine bestimmte marke legen
hauptsache verfahren für die fete stich
brauchen wir wieder 100 gramm vollmilch
kuvertüre schokolade und 30 gramm
erdnussbutter
das ist also die gleiche schicht wie die
erste und jetzt fangen wir an
zuerst einmal müsst ihr euch jetzt
überlegen was für eine form ihr benutzt
und ich nehme jetzt ganz normal seine
glasform eine auflaufform ist es und die
habe ich jetzt doppelt mit
frischhaltefolie belegt weil ansonsten
die sneakers darum geben würden und ihr
müsst ihr später rausheben können
deswegen frischhaltefolie alu folie
eignet sich da übrigens nicht weil die
einfach beim zerreißen würde ich hab das
rezept schon mal gemacht und habe es
auch ausprobiert damit auch wirklich
alles klappt und da hatte ich beim
ersten mal auch diese form benutzt
aber ich hatte das doppelte rezept und
damaris nicas viel zu dick und viel zu
mächtig und die an zwei geschmeckt
geschmacklich arbeitet war einfach viel
zu dick und eigentlich gar nicht so
einen riegel essen weil es viel zu viel
war
und es gibt natürlich auch andere formen
so wie dieser hier das ist auch eine
auflaufform für mich ist jetzt diese
menge perfektes hatte zu ungefähr die
maße 20 mal 20
falls ihr eine andere form habt können
es euch einfach umrechnen oder
pi mal daumen so ein bisschen augenmaß
das geht auch kann auch eine längliche
reform sein und falls ihr noch kleine
reform habt reduziert ihr nochmal die
menge falls eine größere form habt
können das einfach verdoppeln oder eben
mal 15 nehmen diese form verwendet licht
und verweilt jetzt meine gas form die
eben doppelt mit frischhaltefolie
ausgekleidet ist und jetzt sehe es ja
auch hier so ein regel ist ja nicht
dicker erscheint was so einzeln ganz
schön dick aber wenig später als ganze
fläche habt müsst ihr echt schauen dass
es richtig schön flach ist denn
ansonsten kann man das gar nicht essen
das wird dann einfach viel zu mächtig
und der hat so eine höhe von 15 cm würde
ich jetzt mal schätzen und so hoch
sollte es dann eben auch mal bei euch
sein
für die erste schicht nehmt ihr jetzt
die kuvertüre dann nehme ich jetzt voll
milch kuvertüre ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
dass ich mal so der tat bitter fällen
bin aber weil wir ja die sneakers
originalgetreu nachmachen wollen werde
ich jetzt voll milch kuvertüre nehmen
und werde jetzt klein hacken
dann gebt ihr die schokolade in eine
kleine schüssel
hier kommt jetzt die erdnussbutter
direkt mit rein und dann stelle ich das
ganze in ein wasserbad
das heißt ich habe jetzt ihr heißes
wasser und stellt die schüssel hier oben
rein und lassen es langsam schmelzen
man kann die schokolade natürlich auch
in einem temperiergeräte schmelzen oder
in der mikrowelle wobei es in der
mikrowelle etwas gefährlich ist weil die
schokolade schnell verbrennen kann und
mit einem temperiergeräte werde ich es
euch auch mal zeigen
ich habe jetzt nur noch ganz kleine
stückchen drin und habe jetzt die
schokolade bereits aus dem wasserbad
herausgenommen und es ist wirklich die
sicherste methode mit einem tempel gerät
zu arbeiten weil dann einfach die
optimale temperatur für eure schokolade
habt das dauert zwar ab und zu länger
weil eben das temperiergeräte nur auf
die temperatur auch erhitzt wie es
braucht also auf etwa 30 grad
aber es ist eben so dass dann die
schokolade auch wirklich schön glänzt
und festwirt und die schokolade einfach
richtig temperiert wird wenn die
schokolade dann geschmolzen ist gibt es
sie in eurer auflaufform rhein und die
schokolade verteilt ihr jetzt am besten
so einfach durch hin und her schwenken
muss die erste schicht erst mal fest
werden das heißt ich gebe es jetzt für
etwa eine viertelstunde als 15 minuten
ins gefrierfach
da wird einfach am schnellsten fest
falls er kein gefrierfach habt oder es
zu kleines oder voll ist können das
natürlich auch einen kühlschrank geben
da dauert es etwas länger vielleicht 20
bis 30 minuten auf jeden fall wenn ihr
die schokolade anfangs darf sie nicht
mehr feucht sein
und dann machen wir weiter wenn die
erste schicht am fest geworden ist könnt
ihr die zweite schicht vorbereiten
und dafür braucht jetzt zuerst mal die
butter die kondensmilch und den zucker
die wird jetzt nämlich in einem kleinen
topf gekocht und dann kommen die
restlichen drei zutaten also
marshmallows live erdnussbutter und
ereignisse dazu
den kleinen topf gebe ich jetzt die
butter die kondensmilch und den zucker
und lass die drei zutaten zusammen
richtig schön aufkochen
und sobald es dann kocht müsst ihr eben
immer schön weiteren damit sich anbrennt
und ich lasse es ist etwa 1 bis 2
minuten köcheln bis es eine etwas
cremige masse ergibt und dann nehme ich
das vom herzen
thimister aufpassen dass es euch unten
nicht anbrennt ist jetzt beispielsweise
hier was ist ziemlich schnell dass es
dann etwas braun wird und deswegen
nehmen das lieber früher vom herd und
rührt auch immer schön weiter
da kommt jetzt die erdnussbutter dazu
sie löst sich dann natürlich richtig
schön in der wärme auf und jetzt kommt
hier dieses marshmallow flaf dazu
und das wird dann jetzt auch einmal
einen gegründet und wenn ihr das dann
habt kommen da noch die erdnüsse mit
dazu
das kann soweit habt könnt ihr euch
diese feste masse rausnehmen und da wird
es jetzt drauf gestrichen da geht das
jetzt ganz schnell drauf damit die masse
nicht fest wird bevor sie verstrichen
habt und ihr seht ich gebe jetzt hier
schon die erdnüsse mit dazu und nicht
erst in die karamell schicht denn die
ergebnisse sind jetzt sehr uneben und
wir möchten ja aber dass die sneakers
regel später oben blatt werden
und deswegen gibt es jetzt hier auch
schon mit dazu denn ansonsten hätten wir
unter der schokoladen schicht direkt bei
dem karamell listen die erdnüsse und es
wäre natürlich dann sehr uneben und
hügelig und ihr meint hier schon während
dem verstreichen dass es schon fest wird
weil einfach die schokolade richtig
schön kalt ist und das macht er jetzt so
eben wie möglich und ich wette jetzt
auch noch mit einer karte darüber
streichen mit einer tankkarte das müsst
ihr natürlich nicht
das könnt ihr damit nochmal schön glatt
wird und so ist schicht nummer 2 auch
fertig und darf jetzt ist der vielfach
und jetzt möchte ich noch ganz kurz was
zum flaf sagen und zwar ist es ein
amerikanisches produkt dieses
marshmallow flach das wird ebenso
genannt
das benutzen die amerikaner einfach auch
als brotaufstrich und vom geschmack her
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen wie diese
füllung aus den mooren köpfen als ich
abi ziehenden mauern kopf aufgeschnitten
und diese füllung hier ihnen das ist
eigentlich auch ein marshmallow flach
oder eine marshmallow füllung und so
könnt ihr euch das geschmacklich
vorstellen
und dieses fleisch gibt es wie gesagt
bei uns beim globus und man kann sie
auch selbst machen
das zeigt ja was am ende des videos
damit jetzt nicht so lange wird ich
finde es persönlich als brotaufstrich
viel zu süß weil sie einfach nur eiweiß
und zucker ist aber in den speakers und
in anderen regeln wirklich super wenn
die zweite schicht am fest ist könnt ihr
mit der dritten beginne und mit der
beginnt ja auch wirklich erst wenn die
zweite feste ist also die zweite wird
nicht hart weil ist diese flüssige masse
ist also diese marshmallow fleischmasse
und das ist es ein weiter lockert aber
wenn ihr merkt es ist schön kalt um die
oberfläche ist fest und tätigt mehr
beginnt
der dritten schicht und da brauchen wir
nur die zwei zutaten diese
karamellbonbons und kondensmilch und die
erwärmen wir jetzt wieder am herd und
dafür gibt jetzt diese bonbons in den
kleinen topf wie gesagt habe ich da
jetzt diese durch pfizer genommen aber
diese musik in natürlich auch und dann
gibt es noch die content bei mir steht
jetzt der herd auf höchster stufe dass
es auch okay so müsste einfach es dabei
bleiben und die lösen sich dann so
langsam in dieser warmen milch auf es
dauert ein paar minuten
und sobald sie aufgelöst sind nämlich
sie vom herunter und kondensmilch ist
übrigens diese hier ich habe jetzt die
von bärenmarke die gibt es aber auch von
ganz vielen anderen marken die habe ich
jetzt auch bei globus gekauft die steht
bei uns bei mehl und so weiter und dann
eben dran stehen eben diese fertig
milchpackungen ich schalte sitzen ein
bisschen runter weil ich nicht möchte
dass es jetzt kocht sondern dass ich das
jetzt einfach schön auflöst jetzt hat
sich das alles aufgelöst und jetzt
nämlich vom herd runter und diese masse
ist jetzt richtig schön fest also das
können da gut sehen und da gebe ich
jetzt dieses karamell obendrauf
ganz vorsichtig und dann nehmt ihr so
viel wie ihr möchtet
ich mache es nur eine dünne schicht
damit schneiden einfacher wird bei mir
bleibt so ein bisschen übrig das waren
jetzt vielleicht 456 bonbons und das ist
okay so und das gebe ich das nicht mit
drauf da kommt sie auch wirklich darauf
an wie groß das im endeffekt eure form
ist das lasse ich jetzt weg kann das auf
dem eis geben oder so und das hier
verwende ich gleich
bei der karamell schicht entscheidet ihr
wie ich sie haben wollte aber mit
bedenken je dicker die schicht ist umso
schwieriger wird es dann die sneakers zu
schneiden
ihr wisst ihr was wir mal passiert war
mit meinem double chocolate cheesecake
als die karamell schichte dick war
da ich mir der ganze kuchen kaputt
gegangen und deswegen lasse ich die
karamell schicht jetzt beim sneakers
etwas dünner
die werde ich jetzt einfach gar nicht
weiter verwenden denn erst durch die
kälte von dieser nougat masse wird auch
der karamell fest und bevor jetzt wieder
steinhart wird wäre das sowieso nicht
aber bevor er zu hart werte werde ich
dir jetzt gleich aufschneiden und wenn
sie gleich weiterverarbeiten
jetzt werde ich das hier einfach schön
rausziehen das ist echt ganz sorgsam
machen
ihr merkt jetzt ob es kalt genug ist und
zwar wenn er auf die folie abziehen
wollte und das karamell hängt hier dran
können das noch nicht abziehen das heißt
ich gebe es jetzt noch mal kurz ins
gefrierfach lass es wieder etwas an
gefrieren und wenn sich dann die folie
ganz leicht von karamell löst dann ist
es soweit und kann geschnitten werden
dies könnte das ganz einfach abziehen
es kann ich das auf meine schneidebrett
legen
und ich sehe jetzt hier auch ganz toll
geschichten also unten die schokolade
dann diese lukas schicht und jetzt die
karamell schicht jetzt muss das ganze
natürlich geschnitten werden sie jetzt
hier die sneakers mini und hier die
normalen sneakers von der dicke her sind
sie auch super die selbstgemachten wer
schützt es hier zu groß deswegen werde
ich sie etwas kleiner schneiden und
nehme jetzt mein messer und zeichne mit
es erstmal oben ein
es nehme ich mein langes scharfes
konditor besser und schreibt das in
einem zug durch
jetzt vor mich mal dass nico es erstmal
wieder bisschen schön denn gleich
komplette schokolade und der abschluss
gebe ich mir meine back folie auf meine
arbeitsplatte dann könnte aber auch ein
backpapier benutzen und gibt da an am
tropf gitter drauf also ein abkühlen
gitter und hier gebe ich jetzt meine
sneakers drauf und die werde ich jetzt
gleich mit schokolade überzogen und
setzte darauf dann auch wieder abtropfen
lassen
die vierte schicht brauchen wir wieder
100 gramm vollmilch kuvertüre und 30
gramm erdnussbutter und dafür fahren wir
über erstmal auch als er die schokolade
klein hacken im wasserbad mit dem mit
erdnussbutter zusammenschmelzen
und dann verwenden wir sie weiter und
jetzt habe ich hier meine temperierte
schokolade mit der erdnussbutter und
gebe jetzt einen sneakers auf eine gabel
und nehme mir jetzt einen löffel und
lass die schokolade jetzt einfach drüber
laufen so dass alles bedeckt ist
dann klopfe ich zwei drei mal auf die
gabe so über den baum hieß hatte ich das
genauso gemacht
dem standen runtersetzen und jetzt setzt
sich das auf mein abdruck gitter und da
kann es noch weiter tropfen und wenn es
tropft dann tropft eben auch diese back
folie und nicht auf die arbeitsplatte
so gibt's natürlich auch viel schneller
sehen sie jetzt bei mir aus ich habe
jetzt nicht alle überzogen die werde ich
nämlich die restlichen hier morgen abend
überziehen und setzte dann am montag mit
in die schule leben für meine kollegen
die freuen sich da auch immer und jetzt
könnt ihr hier wenn ihr möchtet auch
noch ein muster reinziehen sie hier
dafür nimmt ihr dann eure gabel oder
euren löffel oder irgendwas und könnt
hier zum beispiel noch so muster reim
machen
die gebe ich jetzt noch mal in den
kühlschrank und wird sie fest werden
lassen und dann zeige ich euch das
endergebnis
und wieder einmal ist es so weit ich
darf ich jetzt meiner selbst gemachten
nachgemachten originale präsentieren
und ich muss jetzt schon sagen ich habe
schon ein bisschen genascht während ich
gewartet habe
und bisher war es immer so also bei der
mieter war so bei den baum thies war es
so bei dem teller was so und jetzt bei
den sneakers es so immer schmeckt mir
das nachgemachte besser als das original
und hier sind jetzt die nachgemachten
sneakers hier die originale mini und
nummer und hier die nachgemachten hier
habe ich noch welche ohne schokolade ich
einfach das tolle inneren noch mal
zeigen wollte wie toll dass hier einfach
aussieht und ich muss dazu sagen im
originalrezept aus dem amerikanischen
ich habe das ein bisschen abgewandelt
und da waren in der neugasse 200 gramm
zucker drin plus diesen marshmallow
flach und ich habe jetzt beim ersten mal
als ich das rezept ausprobiert hat
wirklich auf 200 gramm zucker genommen
und uns war das definitiv zu süß und bei
diesem rezept habe ich jetzt nur 80
gramm genommen und ich finde sie so
richtig perfekt also es ist entweder zu
süß noch zu wenig süß
und so ist auch die konsistenz richtig
von dieser nugg.ad masse und so sind
echt gut und deswegen frage ich mich
immer mal wieder wieso nimmt man
eigentlich so viel zucker klar ist
zucker auch ein konservierungsstoff da
bleiben die sachen länger frisch und
länger haltbar aber beim nachgemachten
und selbstgemachten finde ich kann man
echt immer gerade bei den amerikanischen
rezepten immer die zuckermenge fast um
die hälfte reduzieren
hier habe ich jetzt noch mal das
originale jetzt mit diesen erdnüssen in
der nachtschicht und meine nachgemachte
version
da sieht man's diese luftschicht und
oben das karamell und dann kommt eben
die schokolade und jetzt natürlich noch
zeit geschmackstest richtig lecker und
cremig auch stark das war ungefähr mein
vater und ich könnte noch zwei weitere
essen man sieht an meinem bauch
jetzt kommt die frage ist der
lieblingssong ein ich bin nicht
schwanger das kommt einfach dadurch dass
ich manchmal viel essen nach dem essen
mein bauch etwas dicker ist
ich bin nicht schwanger
das rezept gibt es natürlich zum
nachlesen auch www.starbett.de ich würde
mich natürlich wahnsinnig freuen wenn
ihr gerade dieses rezept nach macht weil
dieses rezept natürlich auch zum
nachfrage hatte also ich wollte glaube
ich unter jedem nachgemacht video
gefragt ob ich nicht mal sneakers selber
mache und ich habe es jetzt immer ein
bisschen so rausgeschoben weil es
natürlich ein zeitlicher aufwand ist das
immer wieder in den kühlschrank zu geben
oder nicht die friedhofsruhe
insgesamt gesehen ist es ja nicht viel
arbeit also man muss ja eigentlich und
die masse machen kurz verstreichen und
ab in den kühlschrank
aber diese wartezeit zieht sich eben
aber in der zwischenzeit kann man ja
ganz tolle andere sache machen ein paar
youtube videos angucken und dann vergeht
die zeit auch ganz schnell jetzt möchte
ich noch zu einem anderen thema kommen
obwohl nachgemacht das passt jetzt
wirklich gut in dieses video und zwar
möchte ich jetzt auch diese süßen
schwitzen
sprechen kommen die sanierung ist leider
schon im bett zwar hat die liebe
jeanette bei mir im shop die kitchenaid
gekauft und hat mir dann als kleines
dankeschön
diese mützen geschickt und ich dachte
zuerst dass jetzt irgendwo gekauft aber
da war dann ganz dieser brief dabei und
zwar hat sie diese mützen selbst
gehäkelt und anwalt natürlich total
begeistert gerade ich als htw leatherman
und die müsst euch einfach mal angucken
diesem tag holen aus ist krümelmonster
und hier noch und hier noch janetzky hat
eine facebook seite da heißt sie die
bezaubernde jeannie und da verkauft sie
diese mützen auch den link gibt's
natürlich unten in meiner infobox da wo
info steht einfach draufklicken auf mehr
und dann erscheinen da alle links auch
zum rezept und so weiter und sie
verkauft diese mützen der normalpreis
liegt glaube ich bei so 24 euro wo ich
ja schon sagen muss dass es wirklich
wirklich günstig ist weil an seiner
mütze sitzt mal locker mal vier stunden
wie in etwa wenn man geübt ist und da
finde ich sehr günstig weil ich einfach
denke gut 24 euro da muss man noch das
material rausrechnen also den gare und
dann hat man 20 euro und pro stunde
arbeitet arbeitet man eben für fünf euro
natürlich macht das ganze spaß und es
macht ihr bestimmt auch ganz viel freude
das zu machen aber wenn ich mir das so
anschaue richtig günstig diese mützen
und da werde ich mich jetzt auch mal
selber dran setzen wenn ich jetzt mal
noch die andere prüfung geschafft habe
ich noch vor mir habe häkeln tue ich das
sowieso gerne und die janet hat da auch
ein ebook dazu als auch eine anleitung
die könnt ihr euch auch kaufen
falls ihr die mützen lieber selbst
machen wollte das lässt sich auch den
link unten rein und möchte natürlich
auch sagen lieber janet vielen vielen
dank für diese ganz tollen mützen die
samira ist total begeistert wir waren
auch schon im kindergarten im
partnerlook und da waren alle auch ganz
begeistert und entweder bestellen sie
jetzt eine mütze oder sie bestellen die
anleitung und stricken und häkeln alles
selber und auf jeden fall solltet ihr da
auch mal vorbeischauen da würde ich mich
auch sehr freuen
und falls ihr euch eine mütze kauft oder
die selbst nach
macht dann dürfte ich sie natürlich bei
der show netz auf die facebook seite
posten aber bitte auch bei mir
das möchte ich dann auch sehen
vielleicht kriegen wir die ganze saison
straße zusammen und und noch zu meiner
nachgemacht reihe unsere kleine familie
also mein mann um die samira und ich w
zum weil einfach meine küche zu klein
geworden ist die platzt aus allen nähten
ich weiß wir sind gerade umgezogen aber
jetzt haben wir eine richtig schöne
tolle bleibe gefunden und eine tolle
wohnung und da möchte ich auch ein paar
möbelstücke selber machen da verrate ich
euch noch gar nicht aus was und wie
sondern das geht dann auch ums thema
recyceln und ab seite und da freue ich
mich auch schon darauf warten
es gibt dann auch so ein paar do it
yourself videos sowie tool time und dann
wirst du aber dr
nein nein das will ich weil ich kann es
dann und du nicht genau auf jeden fall
wie ich es wird jetzt ganz länger in die
länge ziehen
wenn ihr nach dem rezept geht auf www.ad
hoc news.de und fischer rechts links
schaut ihr unten rein ich verlinke euch
alles und drück euch bis zum nächsten
mal
ja stimmt und wenn ihr natürlich wissen
wollt wie man diesen marshmallow und
wenn ihr natürlich wissen wollt wie man
diesen marshmallow flaf macht dann
bleibt jetzt hatten erfolg wird zum
anschluss tschüss
es war schnell of love braucht ihr zwei
weiß eine prise salz und eine prise
weinstein backpulver tier braucht 160
gramm zucker und 160 milliliter wasser
aus dem zucker und dem wasser müsst ihr
jetzt ein zuckersirup erstellen
deswegen gebe ich jetzt beides in einem
kleinen topf und weites aufkochen lassen
und dann in fünf bis sechs minuten
einkochen lassen damit ebenso ein
dickflüssiger sirup entsteht und in der
zwischenzeit werde ich dann in meiner
kitchenette das eiweiß steif schlagen
aber weil die kitchenaid ja so
leistungsstark ist lasse ich jetzt erst
den sirup kochen und wird es danach
machen falls er aber mit einem
handrührgerät arbeitet solltet ihr jetzt
schon das eiweiß steif schlagen damit
auch richtig schön fest wird ab dem
punkt jetzt lass ich es etwa fünf
minuten einkochen
damit es eben schön dickflüssig wird
jetzt ist es nämlich noch sehr flüssig
und nach etwa der hälfte der zeitweilig
beginnen
das eiweiß steif zu schlagen jetzt werde
ich hier in der kitchenaid mein eiweiß
steif schlagen und gibt da auch direkt
das salz und es war ein stein backpulver
mit dazu und es muss jetzt auch richtig
schön fest werden
und euer zuckersirup ist bereit wenn ihr
seht dass sich nur noch kleine bläschen
auf der oberfläche bilden dann ist er
genug eingekocht ich werde jetzt die
küchenmaschine auf die niedrigste stufe
starten und stand in heißen zuckersirup
einrühren und wird dann bei höchster
stufe fünf minuten weiter schlagen
wenn die masse dann fertig ist könnt ihr
euch das in einem schraubglas abfüll und
dem kühlschrank lagern da hält sich das
so zwei drei tage ich muss mir jetzt 100
gramm davon ab weil ich es sehr für
meine sneakers benötige und den rest
gebe ich einfach in den kühlschrank
aus dieser masse bekommt ihr jetzt etwa
200 gramm
das heißt wenn ihr das jetzt nur für die
sneakers vorbereiten wollt nehmt ihr die
hälfte der zutaten
josef